quand on regarde les sympathisants LR ou
les sympathisants de droite ou les
électeurs de Valérie Pécresse moi ce qui
me frappe c'est à quel point ils sont
favorables à une majorité entre deux
tiers et 3/4 sont les enquêtes sur le
curseur 62 680 alors il y a pas encore
eu d'enquête sur l'ensemble de la
réforme donc soyons prudents ça ne
m'étonne pas parce qu'on vous a un
phénomène depuis le début de l'air
Macron que j'avais appelé d'ailleurs
dans le Figaro la Sainte Alliance LR l
REM c'est à dire LR ou Renaissance
maintenant c'est à dire sur les réformes
de structures une convergence d'adhésion
et de soutien entre sympathisants de
droite et sympathisant d'Emmanuel Macron
quand bien même au début du quinquennat
on avait une base qui était très à
gauche vous en parliez François-Xavier
sur les les ordonnances loi travail de
septembre octobre 2017 sous la réforme
de la SNCF en 2018 sur la première
réforme des retraites celle d'Edouard
Philippe de du 4D troc et décembre on a
eu cette convergence donc c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué pour les républicains ou
la ligne Aurélien Pradier d'être trop
dissonant par rapport à ces
sympathisants de droite même si on n'est
pas sur une logique électorale un tiers
ou un quart qui sont défavorables et on
verra je le répète ce que donneront les
premières enquêtes ce n'est pas rien
mais en tout cas il y a quand même
le risque d'une incohérence si la droite
était opposée farouchement à une réforme
que ces électeurs souhaitent et puis que
on en a parlé fallait Pécresse pendant
sa pendant cette longue campagne quand
même depuis sa candidature depuis sa
victoire à la primaire LR a quand même
porté comme étendard comme comment dire
dans son offre programmatique au plus
haut c'est à dire que est-ce qu'il y a
encore du du grain à moudre j'allais
dire on connaît les grandes lignes là
exposées par Elisabeth borne et ses
ministres sur le projet
mais ce qu'on sait si il y a des choses
qui peuvent bouger encore dans les 50
jours de débat qui pourraient amener des
élus droit ou gauche à changer leur vie
du parti des républicains qui a un peu
plus modéré quant à l'adhésion au texte
ne repose pas forcément sur la retraite
à 64 ans mais sur certaines subtilités
notamment au niveau de la revalorisation
des petites retraites dans le texte qui
a été présenté par Elisabeth borne on
nous parle d'un d'une retraite minimum
qui serait porté à 85% du SMIC ce qui
équivaut à peu près un peu moins de 2200
euros et vous avez certains élus
républicains qui ont twitté dans la
foulée pour expliquer qu'ils aimeraient
avoir la confirmation que ce minimum de
retraite pourrait être aussi appliqué
aux personnes qui sont déjà en retraite
et non ceux qui non seulement ceux qui
rentrent en retraite donc je pense qu'il
y aura quelques subtilités comme ça qui
peuvent être améliorés par le
gouvernement mais qui qui je pense le
seront parce que pour donner quelques
chiffres on parle enfin côté
gouvernement on parle d'une nécessité de
cette réforme des retraites parce qu'on
prévoit un déficit notamment notamment
en 2030 d'un peu près d'un peu plus de
entre 10 et 13 milliards d'euros là avec
la réforme qui est qui est présentée ça
ferait combler ce déficit et ça
permettrait aussi de dégager de l'argent
justement pour financer la
revolarisation de de ces petites
retraites donc à mon sens ce sera
vraiment ce point qui qui tient à cœur
et ils l'ont exprimé à cette partie de
la droite un peu plus réservée d'accord
finalement
Nicolas Sarkozy pendant la campagne
présidentielle disait il faut qu'il y a
une alliance
DLR avec Emmanuel Macron alors alliance
plus ou moins formelle ou pas est-ce
qu'on y est là
on se rapproche mais alors il y a
quelque chose qui a fondément
fondamentalement changé entre l'élection
présidentielle et aujourd'hui c'est
Emmanuel Macron ne veut plus présenter
et donc ça ça engage moins les
républicains de soutenir un projet
qu'ils ont eux-mêmes défendu auprès de
leurs électeurs pendant une campagne
aujourd'hui que dans le précédent
quinquennat où il y avait l'élection
présidentielle en ligne de mien là le
jeu est ouvert le soutien à une réforme
Macron aujourd'hui coûte moins cher
qu'hier donc
Erik sotti peut y aller sans crainte
trop de trop de casse mais son soutien
c'est une monnaie d'échange à très très
forte valeur parce que
il est pas gratuit ce vote qui va
apporter à Emmanuel Macron il va arriver
avec la facture derrière alors
justement il y a plusieurs textes de loi
qui arrivent et quand il va s'agir de
parler d'immigration par exemple on peut
imaginer que le soutien à la réforme des
retraites va se payer au prix fort et
que là il sera sans doute pas question
d'être de d'aller sur les positions des
mêmes ou en tout cas de défendre des
positions qui soient beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus ferme qu'aujourd'hui sur
les retraites on voit bien d'ailleurs
Jordan Bardella qui dit ce sont des
supplétifs et tout
ils vont avoir à coeur à montrer que
pour les autres
les républicains vont devoir montrer à
partir de de maintenant que non ils sont
pas devenus les alliés de les Alliés
d'Emmanuel Macron alors ça ça joue aussi
à ça joue dans les deux sens on va
parler tout à l'heure de la loi énergie
renouvelable mais ça ça marche aussi
pour les socialistes en particulier
parce que vous parliez d'allier et je
voudrais qu'on voit avec Claire Kong
justement les d'Emmanuel Macron le modem
est horizon mais alors si on a entendu
François Bayrou hier justement qui a
appelé une contribution des entreprises
j'ai l'impression qu'il y en a une
petite d'ailleurs contribution pour les
entreprises
le fait de revenir sur certaines
exonérations donc bénéficier les
entreprises mais ça n'a pas tellement
été détaillé donc il y aura certaines
subtilités justement qui seront qui
seront étudiés mais d'orphelie lui il
était plutôt sur 67 ans à un moment non
c'est ça donc ça lui va pas là c'est 64
ans aussi puisque qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire là dessus qu'est-ce qui
jusqu'où il remplit il a parlé
aujourd'hui il a il a dit qu'il
soutenait la réforme mais sans le sans
le dire trop fort sans se mettre trop
trop en avant en fait Édouard Philippe
il a il a un sujet avec 2027 parce qu'à
un moment il va bien falloir qu'ils
tranche avec Emmanuel Macron lui il veut
bien assumer le premier quinquennat mais
s'il veut y aller en 2027 il toujours
cette idée de rupture et donc de montrer
que il est pas tout à fait dans le camp
du président donc il y a le premier
quinquennat qui l'assume ou lui il a
défendait la réforme des retraites avec
le 49-3 donc il s'est pas faite à cause
du covid mais au deuxième partie le
deuxième quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
il va devoir se démarquer à un moment et
c'est c'est pour ça qu'ils pas trop trop
en première ligne en ce moment ni en
soutien fait la porte un soutien modéré
modéré voilà ou alors en soutenant les
ministres comme Olivier du soft qui ne
jamais prendre beaucoup de risques et
oui effectivement
Édouard Philippe il porte aussi
cette cette idée de la réforme des
retraites complètement avortée qui se
serait terminée par un 49,3 donc c'est
vrai que on comprend sa position
quand on voit le paysage là tel qu'il se
dessine à l'Assemblée nationale
Elisabeth borne peut éviter le recours
aux 49-3 bah si leur stratégie de faire
durer le débat et en même temps sans que
la colère
s'enlise si vous voulez tout va dépendre
aussi de la réception des mouvements
sociaux
ça peut ça peut aller comme sur des
roulettes en effet mais de toute façon
vu que c'est un texte financier s'ils
ont recours au 49-3 ce sera pas grillé
la seule cartouche qui le voilà il faut
le rappeler effectivement alors sur un
texte financier vous pouvez avoir
recours
au 49.3
par rapport à d'autres d'autres textes
donc le même là ce serait enfin au pire
il y a un 49-3 derrière il y a une
potion de censure mais c'est pas ça sera
pas voté non il y a du il y a déjà eu
beaucoup d'émotions de censure déposées
il me dit une dizaine à peu près il y en
a aucune qui est qui est passé la la clé
lorsque disait Jordan par derrière c'est
effectivement les républicains c'est la
partie c'est une motion ne peut passer
que si les républicains la vente
[Musique]